you have to understand I'm taking these
things very personally because it is my
family and that is my dad Lindsay
Chrisley's not here for the not so nice
public reaction to her family's crisis
what we will not do is we will not break
as parents Todd and Julie prepare to
spend more than a decade Behind Bars the
past few months have been extremely hard
for me and my family I'm absolutely
heartbroken and devastated last month
the reality stars received a combined
sentence of 19 years in prison now the
daughter Lindsay's speaking out on her
podcast I had been sitting pretty quiet
regarding all of my family staff my
parents sentencing this is not my
favorite thing to ever do and the 33
year old slamming comments about the
situation I had been scrolling on
Facebook over the weekend and ran across
this Facebook post and it was a
photoshopped
picture of my dad and the Tiger King and
it was sexually suggestive and I'm
taking these things very personally
because it is my family and that is my
dad it
dehumanizing in June Todd and Julie were
convicted of bank fraud and tax evasion
a couple plans to appeal the sentencing
has to happen first in order for you to
file for an appeal and well immediately
be doing that we signed up for a show
that has entertained millions and
millions and millions of people what we
didn't sign up for is to be lied on one
silver lining amid the mess Todd's
reconciliation with Lindsay the two were
previously estranged for years there
will never be a Reconciliation there was
just some kind of emotional battle that
Lindsay has had within herself they
patched things up in the wake of the
convictions I'm heartbroken I'm
navigating this process the best way I
know how as a mother as a sister
as a daughter and as a friend and at the
end of the day this is a real family and
it's my family and these are real and
raw emotions another family reaction
Lindsay's brother and sister Savannah
and Grayson I've never seen two people
my parents be so steadfast in their
faith that's Savannah speaking
exclusively to E.T before Todd and
Julie's sentences were handed down in
the end the truth will prevail may get
harder before it gets easier but we have
faith in the aftermath Grayson joins
Savannah on her podcast we're always
going to be the children of our parents
but we also have to learn that just
because our parents are our parents it
doesn't make them superheroes it doesn't
mean that they're going to do everything
110 correct they're going to mess up
parents are still people yeah they're
still people they make mistakes and
they learn from them just as we do
[Music]